tú
i
[Música]
a
cuando se firmaron los acuerdos de paz
en colombia' en 2016 la unidad de
víctimas calculaba que dos millones y
medio de niños habían sido afectados por
el conflicto armado con la disolución de
la guerrilla de las farc podría pensarse
que esas cifras eran historia pero en
2019 el observatorio niñez y conflicto
armado detectó 222 eventos que afectaron
de manera directa a más de 16.000 niños
y adolescentes ataques directos orfandad
y especialmente el reclutamiento una
práctica común por distintos agentes
armados que se ha recrudecido con la
pandemia los datos dicen que 128 niños
niñas y adolescentes fueron reclutados
en los cinco primeros meses de 2020 una
alternativa ante la falta de escolaridad
pero los ataques a la infancia no vienen
solo de las guerrillas los paramilitares
o los cárteles de droga un informe
mostraba que al menos 314 menores de
edad murieron en los últimos 15 años en
operaciones militares uno de estos
operativos salió a la luz pública a
finales de 2019 y obligó al ministro de
defensa guillermo botero a dimitir en el
operativo habían muerto al menos ocho
menores
[Música]
hay cerca de 8 millones y medio de niños
afectados por la guerra en siria no
solamente en el país sino también en los
países de la región donde viven como
refugiados según unicef los menores son
el eslabón débil del conflicto y los que
más sufren las consecuencias estamos
hablando de una generación perdida de
millones de niños a los que les han
quitado la infancia que no tienen acceso
a la educación y muchos de ellos
simplemente han conocido la guerra las
infraestructuras educativas la mayoría
están afectadas por los bombardeos y hay
dos millones de desplazados internos que
no tienen acceso a la educación porque
viven en campamentos y lo mismo ocurre
con los niños refugiados en los países
de la región esto ha llevado a que niños
menores de 15 años tengan que trabajar o
que sean víctimas de la explotación de
las mafias o que acaben siendo
reclutados por grupos extremistas como
el estado islámico en el peor de los
casos muchos se juegan la vida cruzaron
del mediterráneo para encontrar una vida
mejor en europa
[Música]
según ha informado la cruz roja 1 de
cada 10 niños en el mundo ha sido
afectado por conflictos armados en el
caso de áfrica sub-sahariana tenemos los
conflictos en somalí república
democrática del congo por haber no sólo
algunos ejemplos que han afectado este
sector de la población y en particular
la guerra contra la insurgencia y boko
haram el norte de nigeria ha afectado a
más o menos un millón y medio de niños
según ha informado unicef el secuestro
de más de 200 niñas en 2014 en esta
región puso esta situación en el
panorama mundial pero además de los
niños que son reclutados secuestrados en
este conflicto tenemos que más o menos
450.000 según unicef podrían estar
sufriendo de desnutrición y que de estos
50 mil podrían morir en los próximos
meses a causa de esto organizaciones
internacionales humanitarias que operan
en las ahora encuentran también grandes
dificultades para operar debido a los
problemas de seguridad y también es de
gran preocupación el alto número de
niños que boko haram utiliza para sus
ataques
[Música]